اولى حلقات المواجهه بين الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده والسلطه الفلسطينيه
بدات وزير الامن القومي بنجبير بدا عمله
باقتحام الساحات المسجد الاقصى فرد
الفلسطينيون بالتوجه الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه ما اثر غضب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لتقر سلسله عقوبات تنوعت بين الشخصيه
والماليه والميدانيه هذه الاجراءات لن
تسنينا عن مواصله عراقنا السياسي
والدبلوماسي وعلى المسار القانوني الدولي
ليس فقط
لمحاصره حكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه اكثر
التطرفا في تاريخ دوله الاحتلال وانما
ايضا لمسالتها ومحاسبتها ووضح حد لافلاتها
المستمر من همم العقاب نحن نطالب المجتمع
الدولي والاداره الامريكيه بسرعه التدخل
للجسم هذه الحكومه المتطرفه ووضع حد
لتنفيذ برنامجا الاستعماري
وفقا مصادر اسرائيليه فان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اختارت عقوبات محدده بحيث لا
تؤثر بشكل مباشر على الانتعاش الاقتصادي
للمواطن الفلسطيني ولا تضر بالمنظومه
الامنيه لسلطه الفلسطينيه
العقوبات استهدفت عرقله حركه بعض
المسؤولين السياسيين واستمرار مصادره جزء
من اموال الحكومه الى جانب مواصله التطبيق
على المؤسسات القانونيه والحقوقيه العامله
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه والغاء بعض
الموافقات على البناء في المناطق
الفلسطينيه الخاضعه لسيطره اسرائيل اخطر
ما في هذه الاجراءات انها تاتي ضمن برنامج
حكومه وسياسه معلنه وخطوط عريضه تدعو الى
تقويض السلطه بشكل
الضفه ويحسن الصراع ربما هذا يجعلها يعني
حلقه في سلسله اكثر خطوره وابعد مدى على
المدى المنظور خاصه في بيتعلق بالسرعه
وحسمه يدرك الفلسطينيون ان الاخضر في توجه
الحكومه الاس تغطيه الحاليه لم يتبعد
والذي قد يكون على شكل عمليات عسكريه
واسعه ضد مدن فلسطينيه بعينها هو شرعنه
بؤر استيطانيه ومصادره اراضي واسعه تنهي
اي امل باقامه دوله فلسطينيه متصله سبقا
لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
في قمه مواجهته مع حركه حماس في غزه ان
سمح بتدفق الاموال الى القطاع وحافظ على
تنسيق الامن مع السلطه الفلسطينيه اذا
فالوضع الاقتصادي العام للفلسطينيين وقوه
السلطه من الناحيه الامنيه هي مصلحه
لاسرائيل فهل سيحافظوا نتنياهو على هذه
السياسه امس يدفعه وزراه المتطرفون لتغيير
هذه السياسه وتغيير قواعد اللعبه برمتها
عبد الحفيظ جعوان على العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه